welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Linda lorimer the vice president and
secretary of Yale since 1993 miss
Lorimer has served as the senior
counselor to President Levin and is the
leader of major strategic initiatives
for Yale in recent years she has
developed an ambitious strategy and
numerous programs for internationalizing
the university will talk with her today
about those plans welcome is Laura Mars
wonderful to be here so let's begin by
talking about Yale is doing to position
itself as a global university please
give us an overview well actually yell
has been at this for a very long time a
president of Yale about a hundred and
fifty years ago said the university's
role was not to create citizens for the
moment but citizens for the world but
there really has been stepped-up effort
Marilyn in December of 2005 president 11
and I spent time talking with all the
deans of our schools and with over 60
faculty leaders who already are out
around the world with important
scholarly projects to say what should be
the design what should be the shape to
propel Yale to be one of the great
global universities and we created
something called the international
framework which you can find at y le d
you and put an international framework
where we captured the essential three
goals that we heard from our faculty
leaders the first was that we wanted to
be intentional and preparing our own
students here on campus for the lives of
your inner dependency that they will
need to shape the world ahead of us so
that helps influence the curriculum we
have here our second goal was to attract
the best and brightest from around the
world and the third was the audacious to
position Yale as a global University of
consequence so let me just unpack each
of those in terms of preparing our
students and obviously we have an
incredible curriculum here we teach over
50 foreign languages there are over 900
courses that touch upon
tional activities but we said we wanted
to do more so we articulated the goal of
having every Yale College didn't go
abroad once during his or her four years
here and if they were on financial aid
we would give the resources to make it
happen and we have done just that this
past year we had over 1,200 students go
abroad in one year alone but it's not
simply the college that's recraft and
expanding their curriculum I'll just
give two examples from the professional
schools our School of Management
introduced a new curriculum for all
first-year students which has a January
program where every student goes abroad
in groups with a faculty member for a
serious study project so right from the
beginning of their studies we are
capturing this aspect of
internationalization and understanding a
culture in the context of a business or
social responsibility matter for the go
across campus of the architecture school
every third year student in their final
year has an opportunity for a
semester-long studio looking at a
problem in architecture but embedded in
the semester is a travel component also
abroad with their faculty member so
these are enriching activities that we
help will form what a Yale education is
whether you're in the college or whether
you're in one of the graduate or
professional schools but that's our goal
one gold to in attracting the best and
the brightest here obviously the real
lure is the quality of our faculty and
the academic programs but we realize we
should provide a lot more financial aid
through those coming from abroad and we
should give them were support services
so we created a new international center
which held over 800 events last year to
be a home away from home for our growing
number of international students and
scholars a number that has doubled in a
decade we have now about seventeen
percent of our students come from
outside the United States and Canada
some schools are much higher
representation in the music school and
management over thirty percent of the
students come from abroad so that's a
second goal of being a much more
international and welcoming community
the third one the audacious one being a
global University of consequence is
really pursued by our faculty we now
have over 900 faculty members who are
conducting research projects outside the
United States literally in every
continent the some of them are becoming
consequential really quite large I'll
give you two examples in Shanghai we
have a joint fudan university Yale
University Center for genetics its large
75,000 square feet of laboratory space
doing genetics research in sync with the
genetics research being done here at
Yale the director of the shanghai
institute is a full yale professor the
associate director is a shanghai
professor they have virtual lab meetings
by using the internet and showing how
consequential this could be the first
research that warranted being on the
cover of cell magazine leaving a leading
science magazine of course from Asia the
first research from Asia to garner the
cover was emanating from the Sudan Yale
Center in Shanghai so this is an example
of how by working in tandem with an
institution around the world we can make
a real difference but let me go to a
different part of the world if you look
in Ghana we have a joint center with the
University of Ghana and faculty from our
department of infectious medicine
looking at issues of hookworm malaria
and other kinds of infectious diseases
where obviously our faculty benefit as
much as they contribute by being in that
environment which of course has the the
underlying biological and medical issues
right there at had these are both in the
areas of science but we have fascinating
and important work being done in the
humanities and the social sciences and
by all of our professional schools as
well
okay you touched a little bit about on
China so China India and the Middle East
are very much in the news today what are
yells plans in those areas well they
have different strategies for each so
I'll try and describe them briefly okay
in China Yale has a distinction of the
university with the longest ties to that
country when the first young boy left
China to study outside of the mainland
it came all the way to New Haven
Connecticut in 1850 so our heritage is
very very very long and if you look at
the number of projects our faculty
members are conducting in China right
now they number over 80 so they are in
over 17 cities really dotting the
landscape of that great country we have
programs whether it's from the law
school with the China Law Center we have
some of our humanities faculty doing
very important work on families home
village work we also have a program for
university presidents of china's leading
universities who have come for the last
several years to study on our campus so
it's a really very set of programs with
China in India our ties are not as
substantial we have had fewer faculty
working historically in India but that's
changing we announced just in November a
major India initiative we're already 18
million dollars has been raised which in
this economy we think it's really quite
exciting it will eventually add seven
professors to the Yale faculty whose
concentration and expertise will be on
the Indian subcontinent in South Asia
more generally we are looking to have
more internships in the summer for our
students and all the schools to go there
so a major initiative in China we're
very pleased the Prime Minister has
selected Yale to do a program for
aspiring parliamentarians some of the
very best young leaders in the Indian
Parliament and they will be coming back
for another session later this semester
the Middle East the Middle East we have
had some projects that go back over a
century saw the first archaeological
expeditions into the region where by
Yale faculty members they continued we
have a major archaeological expedition
and ongoing project in Egypt for
instance by I give that in terms of
archaeology we have Marsha in horn a new
faculty member who's recently come to
the University who was just in the
United Arab Emirates in the last month
looking at a collaboration there and we
did assist our University here so that's
I you know you know a little bit about
what we're looking at in there our
medical school has some major proposals
for collaborations with universities in
Saudi Arabia that we're pursuing and
we've had sort of long-standing ties
with the crown prince scholarship in
Bahrain where they has sent students
both at the undergraduate level and at
the graduate level we're very eager to
have more young students for all of our
schools complem that area I think like
many universities after nine eleven
we've seen a downturn in the students
coming from the region and one of my
messages whenever i go there and a show
like this is to underscore Yale's
eagerness to welcome students and
scholars from the Middle East as well
we've just created in the past several
years an undergraduate major in Middle
Eastern Studies and we have a new
program bringing distinguished scholars
as visiting professors from the Middle
East so we're really ramping up our
efforts for that important part of the
world okay Yale recently established the
Jackson Institute for Global Affairs
tell us a bit about it and what you
expect to see in both the short term and
long term it is so exciting to have
received a fifty-million-dollar gift lab
from susan and john jackson showing
their belief in investing at such a
massive scale in Yale's
internationalization efforts the focus
will be on teaching and on student
courses in contemporary global affairs I
think we recognize that particularly for
our students we want to buttress
versus maneuverability we have available
to students throughout the university
the goal of jackson institute is to have
contemporary global affairs become a
signature for student whether she
attends the law school or he attends the
architecture school or the environment
school that this will be something that
will be an ingredient of your Yale
education so there'll be courses in the
new Institute available for all students
in all schools but as you will know we
have an outstanding master's program in
international relations is really a
jewel it gets some of the finest
students anywhere who are attending
these kinds of schools and the Jackson
Institute will allow additional courses
for those master students will provide
additional financial aid for those
students and will also support our very
popular undergraduate major
international studies so it will take
the very strong base we already have and
contemporary global affairs and build on
it rather dramatically okay moving
forward what do you think will be the
greatest challenge for Yale in its
globalization's efforts well I think the
challenge will be only a short-term one
I do think the economic downturn will
require us to perhaps elongate some of
our investments in terms of when we
could continue to support some of the
schools and sending all of their
students abroad which is a dream I have
that we would perhaps within the next
decade support through great donations
every school to be able to do with our
business school and also what our
architecture in our College has done we
already have some great programs last
year at the music school sent over a
hundred of its students to Korea and to
China so there certainly are
opportunities for our students already
but I think that with the turnaround in
the economy and some other gifts perhaps
not as generous as Jackson's for the
Jackson Institute but other loyal alums
other foundations and certainly the
kinds of important government grants
that the Macmillan Center has been so
successful in securing over the years
will help us
that challenge wonderful sounds like
such exciting things are going on at
Yale good stuff thank you it really is
exciting and I hope that everyone will
look at the vanillin site because what
the work of the Macmillan Center is
extraordinary in advancing yells
internationalisation efforts and also
perhaps look at the galen the world
website to get a better insights into
the plethora of programs we have all
over the world thank you for having me
here thank you very much for joining us
today for more information about ms
lorimer and Yale's globalization efforts
please visit our website at yale edu
backslash Macmillan report be sure to
join us again for another episode of the
Macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Center for International and
area studies at Yale
Oh